pale and exhausted they stumbled out of
buses perhaps unaware that their plight
has caught the world's attention
their evacuation closely coordinated at
the highest levels in both ukraine and
russia
and still took several days
worried that something would go wrong
first everyone had to be vetted by the
russian military
they took photos of us as if we were
criminals front and profile we were
fingerprinted they went through our
phones checked our documents
i was told there was no way back to
mario paul anymore i felt threatened
ina had gone with her daughter to the
azov style steel factory on march 2nd
you can see her in this video
in one of the dark underground shelters
that's where she spent the last eight
weeks
the evacuation was broken by the united
nations and international red cross it
was a mission fraught with danger no we
we traveled through no man's land fairly
well uh we had a couple of security
incidents during the evacuation itself
um
we discovered all we didn't discover the
uh the russian federation soldiers
discovered some mines and some
unexploded ordnance that had to be
cleared so we could get a route in for
the civilians to come out
and there was some more to fire while we
were working to evacuate the civilians a
couple of rounds landed 500 meters away
also i don't know who fired them uh but
it stopped almost as soon as it started
and that was really it
despite the risks anna decided to join
the convoy with her six months old son
her time underground was riddled with
worry about him
and about her mother who got injured and
is now receiving treatment
it was very hard but we managed we had
to boil water with candles because there
wasn't hot water
my father was running under the shell
into other buildings in the complex to
get water
[Music]
over the past two weeks the situation
inside those shelters deteriorated
food was running low the air was poor
and the fighting ever closer people like
valentina who are stuck in the shelter
for two months were cut off from the
world they were not getting any news and
they had no idea what was happening to
their hometown
and when they came out she says
they were shocked
while on the bus she saw pictures of the
building she lived in flattened to the
ground memories of a lifetime gone
my son has no home neither do i have my
flat anymore nothing left everything i
own is on me now i won't ever be back
there are still civilians remaining at
the steel works the un is hoping for
another evacuation soon
more people who will leave their
hometowns knowing they leave behind a
life that will never be again
al jazeera zapotica